Speaker 1: Something that the American right wing
loves doing is blaming the left for the problems
that the right wing has actually created. This
happens. I mentioned this earlier with debt and
deficit. You'll have a Republican president come
in blow up the deficit, accelerating the increase
in the national debt. And then on day two of the
next Democratic president's administration, say,
look at this national debt, which we accelerated
the growth of dramatically during our last time
controlling the White House. That's one example.
But right now, the most prominent example that
I can think of the right saying to the left, you
aren't solving fast enough. A problem we created
is on vaccination. You simultaneously have the
most anti-vaccine group in the United States
being Trump supporting Trump voters, followed
by Republican voters. And at the same time,
you increasingly have the story being told by that
very same right wing, including right wing media,
that Joe Biden is failing because not that many
people have gotten vaccinated because that very
same right wing media apparatus has been attacking
the vaccines. And I am going to go to a clip for
you now. It is unbelievable that this is what they
are saying. Jon Scott, Fox News anchor, and his
guest, Hugo Gurdon, who's the editor in chief for
the right wing publication Washington Examiner.
They did a segment yesterday attacking Joe Biden
because not enough of the United States has gotten
vaccinated, completely ignoring the reality that
for months and months and months, Fox News has
been running segments critical of the vaccines.
Tucker Carlson saying We believe may be thousands
tens of thousands of people could have died from
the vaccine. Was it that I think maybe on Tucker,
it was thousands, not tens of thousands. Others
have said tens of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands. Laura Ingraham has been doing it and on
and on and on. No awareness or at least pretending
not to be aware of that fact. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: And yet this year, we have lost
more people in this country to COVID than we
did during the first year of the pandemic,
when Donald Trump was president. And now we
have the vaccines. Exactly. So exactly. So the
the pandemic exploded in March of 2020, which was
10 months before Donald Trump was out of office.
President Biden, by coincidence, now has been in
office for 10 months. More people have died under
President Biden than under President Trump, and
Biden inherited the vaccine. The vaccines, you
know, he he came into office promising that he was
going to get his arms around this in a way that
the previous administration had not. But his but,
you know, vaccination rate is only 58 percent, him
considerably lower than in other places, really.
Speaker 1: And why is that exact? Tell us
why is the rate so low? What
group is keeping that rate so low?
Speaker 2: So he hasn't got his
arms around it? And as I say,
what this is is just a way of looking like
he's doing something meaningful. But in fact,
not not managing this thing very well at all.
Speaker 1: Joe Biden has only gotten us to 58
now. It's actually 59 percent vaccination. Why
might that be? Well, it's partially because
of Fox News itself. And as Media Matters has
cataloged, Fox has undermined the vaccination
campaign relentlessly, running at least one claim
undermining vaccines nearly every day in a six
month period. Meanwhile, Fox has implemented
its own even more stringent health policy.
Remember, they require daily testing of the
unvaccinated rather than weekly testing,
and they continue to attack, attack, attack the
vaccines. And now they have the audacity to say,
why aren't more people vaccinated here? It's like
saying, why aren't other people quickly putting
out the fires that we're setting? And you say that
as you are setting more and more and more fires,
this is the organization partially responsible
for not enough vaccination in the United States.
And it's this dance that they're doing
between the vaccines may be killing people.
Getting vaccinated should be a choice. Get not
getting vaccinated is is freedom and blah blah
blah. And on the other hand, saying, Listen,
Joe Biden is failing because not enough people
have gotten vaccinated. Biden was going to get
more people vaccinated. And I don't know if you
could analyze this in a few ways. You could say
this is what they've calculated makes sense for
the best ratings. You feed the anti-vax stuff at
night and then during the day you say we recommend
vaccines and Joe Biden hasn't gotten enough people
vaccinated. Maybe it's calculated in that way.
Maybe it's they want to find something for
everyone. So for the people who want to believe
Fox News is not part of the problem, well, you
can say, look, they're saying Joe Biden should
have gotten more people vaccinated. And at the
same time, if you're looking for a, it's your
freedom not to get. Vaccinated, then you tune
in to Tucker or to Laura Ingram or to whatever
you want. We knew they were going to do this when
they were going and just allowing all the anti-vax
conspiracy theories to be on air. But then now
they're also trying to play both sides of it, and
they should be held accountable. Will they
be in any serious way? I don't really know.